does it
make you afraid sometimes about
the fact that one day hey hi like
intelligence
artificial intelligence could be
you know could hurt us or or you know
like because we're
you know because of hollywood of course
you know the movies we watch but but it
seems like
when i hear sometimes elon musk talking
you know like
yeah so elon talks about with ai we're
summoning the demon
he is very concerned and i talked to him
about it
quite a bit he's very concerned about
all the different ways ai could
hurt us humans i tend to believe that
there's a lot more ways in which ai can
make our lives better
and can make life awesome for humans i
think
humans are the ones that can do a lot of
evil things so i'm less worried about ai
i'm more worried about humans
if i look at what you men have done on
on the course of history you know for
for example
in regards to the planet to the the
scale of the universe
i think what i'm afraid is that we have
more
of a destructive force than a
beneficial force so if a height take
that in consideration
in order to protect us against ourselves
it could hurt us in a way i don't know
if you if you understand what like
what do you think about that does it
makes you afraid sometimes
not because of a hype but because of
what humans are doing
that haihai could do to us to prevent us
of hurting ourselves you know yeah no
i mean definitely it can bring out the
the worst in human nature
and uh provide tools
for evil people to do evil things at a
larger scale
but i just think it depends
what you think human beings are i tend
to believe
that as we get more intelligent we
we start to see the value the
evolutionary value
and the value in terms of happiness of
being good to each other and i think ai
if you look at ai as an optimization
problem of how to create a civilization
that works well
and expands throughout the universe i
think love
is much more effective so ai will help
us
maximize that i think there's going to
be
always spikes throughout as it has been
through human history
where charismatic leaders will do evil
onto the world in the name of good you
have the stalin and the hitlers and all
of that
but ultimately
over time i think technology will give
the good uh the good people
power and the evil people
uh less power now there's a lot of ways
in that
in uh that that won't be the case
there's a lot of ways
for it to go wrong and elon talks about
them but
i i honestly think in terms of
intelligent ai
that's going to bring more love to the
world the thing i'm concerned about
is dumb ai so there's been a lot of
discussion
between china and the united states
recently on autonomous weapons system
this is something people don't they're
afraid to talk about
but there's now a race
where the united states has officially
said
that they're not against adding ai to
its weapon systems so now the us
military
is adding automation adding intelligence
to its drones to its uh
anything that can create damage and so
of course
and they did this so in response to
china doing that
so you can imagine this is this is
terminator
you think about terminators intel
intelligent systems they're not
they're pretty dumb the the point is
they're efficient at doing what they do
and uh in the space of war
efficient at doing what you do means
killing
so that i'm really afraid of but those
are dumb ai
those aren't your uh loving
deep fulfilling relationships that's
like
uh efficiently being able to fly to plan
the trajectory of dropping bombs
of missiles of how to do counter-attacks
of how to maximize the destruction of a
particular facility instead of
individuals
and then that can just escalate
and as opposed to the cold war with the
with the soviet union
this could be a hot war and then
the consequences once you allow
it's kind of terrifying yeah because
currently the drones are operated by
humans
so you know you have say you have
information about uh intelligence gives
you information about a particular
terrorist located at this area
and then you use drones to
maybe uh the automation there is to help
you
figure out what is the best trajectory
to
strike at that location so you still
have a human that pulls the trigger at
the end
dropping the bomb now automation and ai
in autonomous weapons systems might be
where you say
there's a bad guy over here you figure
out
how to get rid of the bad guy okay so
then
of course the systems will be very good
at finding the right trajectory and so
on
but there's bugs that can happen
unexpected bugs that the system might
figure out that there is
this bad guy might actually be in these
other
five locations so mike's might make
sense to cover the entire area
right and you see you might just drop
bombs on the entire area
and then you know that's just okay so
that's going to lead to a lot of
destruction of the scale of a city
but then you can immediately take that
to nuclear weapons
if you add automation to uh responding
to counter attacks to nuclear weapons
somebody you might get information that
somebody's planning a nuclear attack on
the united states
and the ai system will immediately
respond
and you know it can respond at a scale
of launching nuclear weapons itself
so there's all of these possibilities
that don't require much intelligence
and that's exceptionally that's
exceptionally concerning
i i'm like you i do not believe there is
babies that are born bad i think people
do bad things because of their
experience
however if i look
to my experience and from what i can see
some very often
men's of power wants more power
that's what makes me afraid with yeah no
absolutely
i listen i've been uh i've come from the
soviet union
uh stalin is arguably one of the most
powerful humans in history
uh he's not talked often enough about by
the evils he's done hitler gets all the
attention
yeah but stalin has done arguably much
more evil than uh than hitler
yeah well this is this is human nature
it wants power
we see that with institutions we see
that with governments and nations
i think you see you see this with the
internet
people are really hungry for the
distribution of power
like you see that people are very much
distrustful of centralized places of
power of institutions and so on
so i think successful organizations
successful companies
successful governments will be run by
people who distribute
the power like i don't trust myself with
power at all yeah
and i think you have to build into the
system
that no one person can have power and
that you distribute it that's where you
have
in the financial sector you have
cryptocurrency right now with bitcoin
and all those kinds of things
people are exploring how can we avoid
the central bank
to have the control how do you put the
power in the hands of
people thousands of people millions of
people in the same way with
uh with military with um
any kind of uh with technology
i think the future looks very
distributed so
what do you think about militarizing
space
[Laughter]
the uh space force i i i don't think
about it often because
right now i'm filled with excitement
about space exploration which is the
positive aspect so elon
you know i was born in an era where it
was exciting
i don't know about you but for me it's
exciting to look up to the stars and
dream about us humans ex you know uh
colonizing bars colonizing other planets
expanding onto the galaxy into the
universe
that's really exciting uh so
i'm the the possibilities there are
endless
i don't think because the also the
resources are endless
and so i think we get into trouble with
militarization with wars
when the resources are very constrained
so i think
for a while we're not going to be
fighting
the the only wars we'll be fighting in
space are the ones that kind of
uh help us another nation to compete
yeah
who goes to the moon first i guess
that's those those are kind of
those kinds of things or maybe for
satellites and all those kinds of
communication and
uh maybe in assistance for like cyber
warfare which is also very dangerous but
in terms of
space wars out in space i think
i think uh everything out in space will
be
positive and inspiring it's very hard
but
all good things are hard i think
you